>>> REPUBLICAN CONGRESSMAN-ELECT
GEORGE SANTOS ADMITTING TO
EMBELLISHING PARTS OF HIS
RESUME, AND HE SAID HIS PARENTS
WERE IN THE HOLOCAUST AND HE IS
JEWISH, AND HE SAID THEN WHAT HE
MEANT WAS HE WAS JEW-ISH.
>> I DIDN'T OUT RIGHT LIE ABOUT
MY WORK EXPERIENCE.
I AM ACTUALLY FAIRLY
WELL-ROUNDED IN THE FINANCIAL
MARKETS AND CAPITAL MARKETS AND
HAVE BEEN DOING IT FOR A LONG
TIME.
DID I EMBELLISH MY RESUME?
YES, I DID, AND I AM SORRY.
IT SHOULDN'T BE DONE.
THERE ARE JUST WORDS THAT CAN'T
EXPRESS 100% HOW I FEEL.
BUT I AM STILL THE SAME GUY.
I AM NOT A FRAUD.
THIS WILL NOT DETER ME FROM
BEING AN EFFECTIVE MEMBER OF
CONGRESS IN THE 118th SESSION.
>> AND WE ARE FOLLOWING THIS
STORY.
I CANNOT HELP BUT ASK YOU WHAT
IS THIS "ISH" WE ARE TALKING
ABOUT?
HOW MANY LIES DID HE TELL ALONE?
>> HE'S CHARACTERIZING MANY
FALSE CLAIMS AS EMBELLISHMENTS,
BUT THIS GOES BEYOND THAT, AND
HE SAID HE WORKED FOR CITIGROUP
AND GOLDMAN SACHS, AND HE ADMITS
HE DID NOT.
HE SAID HE RECEIVED DEGREES FROM
TWO COLLEGES THAT HE SAID HE DID
NOT.
HE OWNED 13 DIFFERENT
PROPERTIES, ANOTHER LIE.
HE MAINTAINS HE'S NOT A CRIMINAL
AND STILL INTENDS TO SERVE IN
CONGRESS.
>> AS I SAID MANY TIMES AND I
THINK YOU HEARD ME SAY THIS, I
ALWAYS JOKE I AM CATHOLIC, BUT I
AM ALSO JEW-ISH, AND I GREW UP
AND MY GRANDPARENTS WERE JEWISH
AND WERE REFUGEES.
>> HE DESCRIBED HIMSELF AS A
PROUD AMERICAN JEW IN A DOCUMENT
HE SHARED WITH PROMINENT JEW
ISH
GROUPS.
WE HAVE NOT HEARD FROM KEVIN
McCARTHY SINCE THIS SCANDAL
BROKE.
>> I CAN'T HELP -- THIS IS JUST
CRAZY SAUCE.
THERE ARE SO MANY THINGS THAT AS
YOU GO DOWN THE LIST OF THINGS,
IS THERE ANY INDICATION OF WHY
HE LIED ESPECIALLY ABOUT HIS
RELIGION?
>> YEAH, I THINK THAT THE
QUESTIONS REMAIN THERE.
I KNOW THAT CNN, WE WANT TO
SPEAK WITH HIM.
I IT WILL BE INTERESTING BEFORE
HE SITS BEFORE A LESS
FRIENDLY-MEDIA OUTLET.
BUT TRULY, NO, HE HAS NOT REALLY
DETAILED THE WHY.
I THINK HE MAY BE LEAVING AN
OPENING TO SAY THAT THIS WAS
SORT OF THE FAMILY HISTORY THAT
WAS TOLD TO HIM, AND THAT SEEMS
TO BE WHAT HE IS SUGGESTING TO
GIVE HIM AN OPENING TO SAY THAT
HE DIDN'T ACTUALLY LIE HERE, AND
THIS DOES NOT MAKE A WHOLE LOT
OF SENSE.
I IMAGINE IN THE COMING DAYS WE
WILL CONTINUE TO LEARN MORE.
>> THANK YOU, AS ALWAYS, FOR
GREAT REPORTING THERE.
JOINING ME NOW TO DISCUSS THIS,
CNN POLITICAL COMMENTATOR AND
REPUBLICAN STRATEGIST, ALICE
STEWART.
AND FORMER ADVISER TO VICE
PRESIDENT MIKE PENCE, OLIVIA
TROY.
I WILL START WITH YOU.
SANTOS DESCRIBED THE LIES AS
EMBELLISHMENTS.
YOU TWEETED HIS LIES WERE A
PROBLEM.
THAT SEEMS LIKE A UNDERESTIMATE.
>> CHARACTER COUNTS, AND HE HAS
PROVEN TO BE SOMEBODY WHO IS
DEVOID OF SPEAKING THE TRUTH.
HE REPEATEDLY LIED TO THE PEOPLE
THAT ELECTED HIM TO SERVE IN
CONGRESS, AND IF SO HOW COULD HE
BE TRUSTED TO BE A MEMBER OF
CONGRESS?
HOW COULD HE BE SWORN IN AND
TRUSTED WITH NATIONAL SECURITY
ISSUES AND ISSUES THAT ARE SO
CRITICAL TO OUR COUNTRY, AND
THOSE ARE VALID QUESTIONS.
HE SAYS HE'S NOT A FRAUD.
LOOK AT THE DEFINITION OF FRAUD.
A PERSON WHO KNOWINGLY DECEIVES
OTHERS BY OVERSTATING HIS
ACCOMPLISHMENTS AND QUALITIES.
THAT'S WHAT HE HAS DONE TIME AND
TIME AGAIN.
IN MY VIEW, AND IT'S UP TO THE
PEOPLE IN HIS DISTRICT, BUT I
THINK IT WOULD BE IMPOSSIBLE TO
TRUST HIM AS A MEMBER OF
CONGRESS BECAUSE OF THE LIES.
HE SAYS HE WANTS TO BE SEATED IN
CONGRESS AND SERVE THE PEOPLE OF
HIS DISTRICT, AND I WOULD HIGHLY
RECOMMEND THE REAL GEORGE SANTOS
STANDS UP AND RUN IN TWO YEARS
ON HIS REAL NAME AND
ACCOMPLISHMENTS AND NOT THIS
LEONARDO DiCAPRIO STARRING AS A
CATCH ME IF YOU CAN CHARACTER
AND NOBODY KNOWS WHO HE IS AND
WHAT HE STANDS FOR.
>> THAT WAS A MIC DROP MOMENT,
ALL THE THINGS YOU JUST SAID
THERE.
ALL THE THINGS YOU SAY LOOKING
UP THE WORD FRAUD IS TRUE.
YOU LIE ABOUT EVERYTHING, YOU
EMBELLISH.
AND DO YOU THINK HE HAS DONE ALL
THIS STUFF, SAYING HE IS JEWISH
AND HIS GRANDPARENTS SURVIVED
THE HOLOCAUST, AND NOW HE'S
SAYING HE'S JEW-ISH.
WAS IT TO GET VOTES FOR
DIFFERENT GROUPS OF PEOPLE?
>> IT APPEARS HE WAS PANDERING
TO DIFFERENT GROUPS AND TRYING
TO APPEAL, AND IT APPEARS HE'S
JUST A PATHOLOGICAL LIAR, AND
THAT SPEAKS TO HIS CHARACTER AND
LACK OF INTEGRITY AND CALLS INTO
QUESTION WHAT HE'S GOING TO DO
ONCE IN CONGRESS, AND THERE ARE
QUESTIONS OF WHAT HAPPENED IN
TERMS OF THE CAMPAIGN FINANCE,
AND WHAT REALLY WENT ON THERE?
I THINK THOSE ARE QUESTIONS HE
WILL NEED TO ANSWER TO AND
ACCOUNT FOR.
BUT IN REALITY, THIS IS PLAIN
SICK.
HE LIED ABOUT HAVING FRIENDS IN
THE MASS SHOOTING, AND I THINK
THAT JUST SAYS A LOT ABOUT WHO
HE IS AT THE CORE.
>> THIS IS FOR BOTH OF YOU, AND
I WILL START WITH YOU, OLIVIA.
THERE'S ALWAYS OPPOSITION
RESEARCH OR AS WE CALL IT,
DIGGING UP DIRT, AND HOW DO
DEMOCRATS MISS THIS ONE AS HE
WAS CAMPAIGNING?
>> I ACTUALLY HAVE BEEN
WONDERING THAT.
I DON'T KNOW HOW YOU DON'T
DOUBLE-CHECK THESE THINGS AND
FACT CHECK THEM.
THIS WAS VERY OVERT, AND THEY
REALLY DROPPED THE BALL ON THIS
ONE.
I DON'T NECESSARILY BLAME THEM.
THERE'S LOT GOING ON WHEN YOU
ARE TRYING TO TRACK DOWN THE
PEOPLE RUNNING FOR OFFICE, AND
HE'S JUST ONE CHARLOTTETON THAT
FITS IN WITH THE OTHERS WE ARE
SEEING.
>> WE CALL THEM THE CAMPAIGN
DUMPSTER DIVING.
YOU DO VULNERABILITY RESEARCH ON
YOURSELF TO SEE WHERE YOUR
VULNERABILITIES ARE, AND HIS
CAMPAIGN CLEARLY DROPPED THE
BALL ON THAT.
AS HE BECAME THE GOP NOMINEE,
THE DEMOCRATS SHOULD HAVE HAD
ACCESS TO THE INFORMATION AND
DONE THE RESEARCH ON THIS.
WE KNOW THE DCCC HAS DONE THAT
AND PUT SOME OUT, AND TO THE
DEGREE AND THE MAGNITUDE THAT
THE "NEW YORK TIMES" AND MEDIA
HAS UNCOVERED THE FALSEHOODS,
IT'S SHOCKING IT ALL DID NOT
COME FORWARD.
AND I GIVE CREDIT TO THEM SAYING
IT'S UP TO THE PEOPLE OF THE
DISTRICT AND WHAT THEY DO, AND A
BLANKET APOLOGY IS NOT